- And here to host, please
welcome one of the funniest women
west of the third street promenade y'all.
You can catch her Deal With
It Tour in a city near you
and her new comedy special,
Look At You is on Netflix.
Say hello to Taylor Tomlinson.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Already get a hug-
- Oh my god!
and you look so cute.
- Stop. Okay.
- Look at your outfit.
- Everything's fine.
I'm not freaking out.
Everything's good.
(crowd laughing)
I'm good.
I'm fine.
- Well thank you for hosting.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for this.
(laughing)
- So what was your favorite
Backstreet song growing up?
Cause I could tell you, you were a fan.
- No, I'm totally fine.
Everything's cool.
I feel like this is so crazy.
I feel like I'm sitting
between two tracks of a now
that's what I call music CD.
(Laughing) Like I just wanna take a minute
and thank-
- [Kelly] We made it.
- I wanna thank whoever books this show
for ignoring the discrepancy
between guests today.
This is incredible.
This is like the day you hop back on
the high school group chat.
Like, hey I know I've ignored
everybody's baby shower invites
but I have an update about what I'm doing.
- [Man Conversing] Oh my God.
(laughing)
My favorite Backstreet voice
song was Larger Than Life.
- Larger than life.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
- That they got-
- So that made me-
- Two words.
- Yeah.
- [Taylor] I know, I saw that-
- I was like-
On the card and I was like-
- What!
- All you go.
- Yeah, whatever Brian.